now we're going to move on to the topic
for this chapter which is dealing with
multiple hypothesis tests so now the
situation is that we don't have just one
hypothesis or one null hypothesis we
want to test but m different ones and as
i mentioned at the start
we've had the sort of concept and
statistics forever but the
typical value for m was very small
single digits two or three something
like that and the methods for adjusting
in that situation worked pretty well but
these days we often have situations
where we want to test thousands or tens
of thousands of hypothesis tests and the
complications from that become even
larger so
suppose that we simply rejected all null
hypotheses for which the corresponding
p-value falls below say one percent so
what happens if we do that then if we
reject all of those null hypotheses that
that fall below one percent how many
type one errors are we likely to make
a lot
turns out if m is large a lot and
to sort of illustrate that idea we
constructed a little thought experiment
here it's it's not a very exciting one
but i think it does illustrate pretty
clearly the issue that you can run into
here so let's suppose that we just pick
a coin and uh we flip it ten times check
if it's fair and
by the way my sons uh
both uh have statisticians as parents so
they do this quite a bit just for fun
i was thinking too bad we don't have a
coin right here we could demonstrate
this as you're going to see it's going
to involve flipping a coin a whole bunch
of times but i'm sure you guys don't
have anywhere to go so so well let's
pretend we sort of edited that out and
we got got to the end here so um if we
just did this once and we tossed this
coin ten times then we'll probably get
approximately the same number of heads
and tails roughly five heads and five
tails and if we calculated a p-value for
uh for that null hypothesis that the
coin is fair i.e it has a 50 chance of
landing on heads or tails then it's most
likely that we'll get a relatively large
p-value and we won't reject the null
hypothesis that's the whole way that
hypothesis tests are constructed but now
let's imagine
that instead of just flipping one coin
10 times we somehow find under the sofa
1024
fair coins at this point it's very clear
that this is just a thought experiment
you haven't seen my sofa but
so then we flip this coin each one of
these coins 10 times so we now
this could take a while so we'll edit
that part out but
if we do that
why did we choose 1024 as the number
here daniella
i think it's because that's 2 to the
10th gareth
and so the probability that if we flip
one coin
10 times that we get 10 tails
is
exactly 1 over one thousand and twenty
four one over ten to the uh two to the
ten
so if we flip that many coins ten times
then on average we would expect to get
about one coin where it came tails every
single time and if we were to perform a
hypothesis test on that one particular
coin
we'd get a p value of about point zero
zero two so a very small p value and why
is it point zero zero two carats
because the probability of a coin coming
up tails 10 times in a row is only 0.002
or coming up heads uh 10 times in a row
so right because it's 1 over 10 24 plus
1 over 10 24. there's two ways that we
could get this extreme an outcome
because we would be really surprised if
we think that the coin's probably fair
and that's our null hypothesis we'll be
really surprised if we get 10 tails we'd
be equally surprised to get 10 heads
presumably so that's why to get the
p-value it's 1 over 10 24 plus 1 over 10
24. because we're not specifying that
it's more likely to be tails or heads
under the alternative it's just not
equal
so
if we were to
look at that one particular coin and do
the hypothesis test on that coin it's
almost certain that we would end up
rejecting the null hypothesis
the other coins maybe we don't reject
but the point here is that if we perform
enough hypothesis tests even when we
insist on a very small p-value it's
almost certain that we'll make some in
this case type 1 mistakes this would be
a type 1 mistake because these coins are
in fact fair the null hypothesis is true
but at least for that particular coin
we've incorrectly rejected it
and this slide here i think this cartoon
sort of illustrates this idea pretty
nicely so i'm not sure if you can read
this on the screen but the concept here
is that they perform a hypothesis test
on jelly beans to check if there's a
relationship between jelly beans and
acne
and of course there is no relationship
between jelly beans
i mean we should probably do the
experiment guess
i don't like jelly beans so i'm not
gonna do it but if you want to you can
try but in this particular cartoon at
least they found no relationship they
had a large p value but then the claim
was well maybe it's not jelly beans in
particular it's particular colors of
jelly beans so
you notice here that we have exactly 20
of these cartoons corresponding to 20
different colors in the rectangular big
box
and that color corresponds to 20 colors
and for 19 of those colors they also
failed to reject a null hypothesis with
a p value of 5 but it turned out that
the green jelly beans had a p-value
below five percent
and so you see suddenly here that
there's a newspaper story that green
jelly beans are linked to acne
but the reality is we just performed a
large number of hypothesis tests
probably the null hypothesis was true in
every one of them
but if we do enough we're almost
guaranteed to get one false positive
and so this relates to all the
reproducibility issues and things as
well that
happen these days
and it also relates to the idea that if
you want to either sound really smart or
be really annoying potato potato then
whenever you see a headline about any
kind of scientific or social science
study or anything like that you can just
be like
i think they had a multiple testing
problem and like you're number one
you're probably right but also very
annoying yeah statisticians don't get
invited to a lot of parties
that is definitely but there's probably
more than one reason for that that's
true yeah
okay so this just sort of illustrates
the challenge that we have in doing a
hypothesis test that if we test this
large number of hypotheses all of which
are true we reject any null hypothesis
with a p-value below say one percent
then we're going to have approximately
0.01 times m whatever the value of m is
null hypotheses that we falsely reject
so that's type one errors we're going to
have .01 times m type one errors if all
of the null hypotheses were true so for
example if we had 10 000 tests and all
of the null hypotheses were true then
we'd expect to falsely reject about 100
null hypotheses by chance so suddenly
there's a hundred newspaper articles
about these fantastic discoveries at a
very low p-value when the reality is we
just performed too many hypothesis tests
or at least without correcting for that
issue so a lot of type 1 errors false
positives
all right so then what's sort of an
approach that we can take to try to deal
with this situation we just discussed
that if we perform enough of these
hypothesis tests we're almost certain to
have some type 1 errors we don't want
type 1 errors so
how can we try to control for the
situation where we're doing a lot of
these tests and the sort of most
classical approach here is something
called the family-wise error rate
and the family-wise zero rate is just
defined as the probability that we make
at least one type one error so if you
think about it if you have a low
family-wise error rate then you're
saying that there's a low probability of
making any type 1 errors sounds great
right so this table here is just sort of
an analogous table to daniella's one
that she showed us earlier this again
has sort of the four possible situations
the two possible real states of the
world and the two possible decisions
that we could make here
and the letters here just represent if i
do m of these hypothesis tests how many
of those tests fall into each of these
four buckets and so for example the
bucket that we're really concerned about
here is the one where h0 is true but we
reject h.i that's the type one error
each night he means each night
h o is true
so
v here the the letter v here just
represents the number of type one errors
that we're making out of m hypothesis
here so the family y zero right here is
by definition the probability that v is
greater than one
so to be clear we we know how many null
hypotheses we've rejected and we know
how many we have and rejected so we know
r and we know m minus r and of course we
know m which is the number of hypothesis
tests we've conducted but we don't know
which column what the values in the
columns are so we don't know the value
of v we don't know the value of
s and so on
right but we can in general calculate or
at least approximate the probability
that v is greater than one or this
family y zero rate or we can hope to try
to control what that value is and that's
what we're going to talk about
now are some approaches for trying to
control that family-wise error rate and
just before we go onto that i just want
to say gareth in your courtroom analogy
i think that the idea here is we have m
defendants each of whom is being put on
trial
and
v corresponds to
finding one of the defendants guilty
when in fact none of them are guilty and
we would be really presumably we would
not want to find even one of the m
defendants guilty if in fact they're all
innocent so that's why we're stressed
about the possibility of v being greater
than or equal to one we want that
family-wise error rate the probability
of wrongfully convicting someone to be
very very small wrongly convicting
anyone among the m to be very small what
how does it go better to let 10 innocent
people go
10 guilty people go than to convict one
innocent person so although here they're
all innocent because the family-wise
error rate we're thinking about the null
hypothesis all being true right
okay so controlling the family y zero
rate sounds like a good thing if we have
a small family y zero rate we're likely
to make no type one errors but in
practice it's often hard to actually
control that and and this formula here
sort of illustrates how you might
calculate the family-wise error rate
and what it's really saying is that it's
equal to one minus the probability of
the intersection that we do not falsely
reject the jth null hypothesis
now in practice that probability is hard
to
calculate in a general situation but if
we simplify things and imagine that each
of our hypotheses tests are independent
so that
intersection becomes a product of the
individual probabilities and we assume
that all the null hypotheses are true
and we only reject if the p values less
than alpha then it's not too hard to
show that that family y zero rate is
equal to this one minus alpha to the m
quantity
and so what does that look like for
different values of m and different
values of alpha so this plot here just
shows for three different values of
alpha five percent one percent and point
zero one percent and different values of
m what happens to that family y zero
rate and the dotted line down the bottom
is is at the five percent level so if
you wanted to have a family y zero rate
of five percent what value of m is going
to work for that and
basically what this shows you is that
when m gets even moderately large you
can end up with family-wise error rates
that are close to 100 so
in that sense the family-wise error rate
is not helping you at all because you're
almost certain to make at least one type
1 error here so the way we read this
plot is if you look at the purple curve
like when m equals 50 so when you're at
50 on the x-axis
the purple curve is right around 0.05
and so that means if you reject any null
hypothesis if there p if it's p-value is
below 0.01 but you have 50 null
hypotheses then there's a five percent
chance of making a family wise
error a type one error type one
at least one type one error but you can
see that once you get up to say 500 here
even at that very very low value of
alpha you're already up to about a 40
chance of making at least one type one
error so this family-wise error rate is
essentially a very hard quantity to
control for very large values of m and
the only way to control it is to have
your alpha be tiny and remember alpha is
the type one error that you're trying to
control so it's like the threshold at
which you're going to reject the null
hypothesis if you see a p-value less
than that alpha